hey on today's show we're going to be
talking about friends who judge their
friends we're going to be talking to
a wonderful woman who's got a great
husband and wonderful kids
but is still haunted by her past we're
going to be talking with the young woman
who has to come to terms with the fact
that she can't fix her mother we're
going to talk to a rad er doctor who's
doing everything he can
to care for his staff during hard
traumatic moments
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john de loni show taking your calls
about your life and your relationships
and your dilemmas
what's going on i want to help you
rethink
re-examine reconsider your lives how you
talk to yourself how you talk to your
friends your kids
your neighbors we're going to talk about
love we're going to talk about
loss family issues broken hearts
we may talk about people since it's
october 30th we may
talk about people who are going to
embarrassingly overdress tomorrow
some people dress up 364 days out of a
year
and they save it all up for this one day
when they just have to let the world
know how much they love chewbacca
how much they are just into bubba fat
man
boba fett's what's up and you dress up
364 days
in this one day you dial it up about 42
percent
and you just let your freak flag
fly so you know what let's just all do
this
letter kenny style let's take 30 off
let's just all bring it down
let's be normal people uh this year has
been ridiculous we don't need your
costumes man we don't need your costumes
you know what i'm not even gonna judge
do whatever you want to if you're that
guy
let it ride if you're her if you're her
if you're a cat mom out there
dress up as your pet whatever we're not
gonna think you're weird coven's
whatever dude this world's already a
wreck so whatever's going on in your
heart
your head what call me about your
halloween costume that'll be weird
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
you can email me at ask john ramsey
solutions.com i just i don't get the
halloween costumes i'm going to show
them what i really why
why just wear a name tag word name tag
i don't know dude people just do
whatever is in your heart let's just do
it
all right let's go straight to the
phones today let's go to
uh let's see here who's calling we got
this
let's go to mike in dayton ohio mike
what is up my man how are we doing
good dr john how are you outstanding
outstanding
what can i help you with today ma'am
well hey um a friend of mine
who really looks up to me um has been
thinking about getting engaged
and i'm pretty sure he's going to ask me
to be his best man
however i don't think um either my
friend or his girlfriend are ready to be
married
but i know he'll be really hurt if i
decline to be his best man
what do you think i should do why do you
man why do you think they're not ready
obi-wan kenobi why do you think that
so um both of them have a lot of baggage
that they'll carry into the marriage
both of them come from very broken
families
she is medically disabled and deals with
a lot of anxiety
she's living with her parents and she's
told my wife and i
that she's being emotionally and
verbally abused by her parents at home
and my friend's family is extremely
dysfunctional
both parents were previously divorced
before marrying each other
there's a lot of anger and in the past
there's been a lot of physical and
verbal violence
and additionally to my friend
financially
um he's not doing so well right now and
i feel like
supporting a spouse especially someone
who's disabled
and can't work but is not on this
ability
i feel like that will be really taxing
for a young marriage
yeah so
here's the deal mike i can give you what
i really think
or i can give you a clean pat stock
answer which one would you like
i would appreciate your honesty okay
i think more than anything in the whole
wide world
your best friend his fiancee
they need people to lean into their
lives not out of them
and i think one of the challenges that
we all face in this world is that we
find people who are
have really difficult lives whose lives
are different than ours whose lives
we don't agree with whose lives have
just taken different shapes and forms
for whatever reason because of
disabilities because of childhood abuse
because of ongoing abuse
because of they look different they love
different all these different reasons
and what we choose to do is to sh we
vote with our feet we show
our disapproval by backing out
and what i would tell you is is that
if i'm in your situation this is all i
can all i can
um the only advice i can give you
brother is if i'm you
i would take my friend out and i tell
him i love him
i would tell him i think this is going
to be really hard i don't know you're in
a good spot to get married
but if you choose to go through with it
i'm going to be right
by your side
because this doesn't sound like a a
a values issue or a morals issue this
sounds like
you have some things in your head that
you think you've established as
credible reasons to get married
um people need to be at a certain place
before they take this plunge
um there may be some a lot of statistics
leaning up against the success of this
marriage
there's gonna be a lot of challenges um
i don't think that's a reason to bail on
your buddy
that's what i think okay
um you sound like you disagree with me
why do you disagree with me
um so my wife and i are pretty newly
married we've been married for about 18
months
and i think
having a little bit of experience under
our belts
we've seen firsthand how
our upbringing affects our relationship
with each other
and the conflict that it brings um so i
think i'm struggling to see
um especially since they're both so
emotionally
um immature um
i i really see a lot of struggle with
them and especially their first couple
years of marriage
um and i don't see a lot of um
willingness to adapt
to each other um and to love
unconditionally and to be patient with
each other
um so i think i think that's why i'm
i'm really hesitant to um
i don't want to say put my put my seal
of approval on their marriage
but i know that this guy really looks up
to my opinion
and i don't want to mislead him by
giving him my blessing
essentially um so i think i think that's
what i'm struggling with
man this your friendship dude doesn't
sound
equitable to me it sounds like you are
you have a tiny sliver of experience
you've been married 18 months
i've been married almost two decades man
and it just goes in seasons and there
are some seasons that are incredible
and some that are a roaring dumpster
fire
and it sounds like you've got a lot of
judgment up against him and not a lot of
experience to back up that judgment
it sounds like you're bringing your
baggage and looking through his
relationship
with your pair of glasses on men and
that's that's a tough thing to do to
your buddy
on the other side i don't disagree with
you man
i've had friends that had no business
getting married and i told them as such
hey dude you're not in a good place man
i don't ever want somebody to not get
married to somebody because it's going
to be challenging
because all marriages are challenging i
don't ever want someone to not get
married to somebody because they have a
disability
i i just i hate that i it makes me
that makes me in my core my guts just
sick um i want people to go in with open
eyes
yeah you're taking on a different life
it's gonna be have different challenges
but it can have different rewards and
successes too
i i look at being somebody's best man
less
as a stamp of approval and more i'm
shoulder to shoulder with you because i
love you and i care about you
now if there's a values thing if i have
a buddy who's married to somebody
and he's going to go get married to
somebody else
and he wants me to come stand in there
i'm not going to do that right
but i'm going to tell him i love you
dude but i was at your first wedding and
then
you've got some stuff going on like
that's gonna be a values thing for me
but this sounds like a judgment thing as
as opposed to a
values thing it doesn't sound like
you're gonna do it
and if you don't wanna do it that's cool
man um
i i i really want you to go look in the
mirror though you are bringing a lot of
judgment to your buddy
you don't have very much experience to
back that up if you've been married two
decades you've been married 10 years
and you could sit down and walk him
through some challenges and
with some with some true wisdom man i'm
all for that
um but i think what he needs right now
is he needs his best friend he needs his
buddy
to not judge him as much as to sit with
him and say are you thinking this
through
i love you and i'm seeing something from
a different perspective here's my
experience
let's talk about it and then you're
gonna have to make a decision if you
think your presence so you're just
showing up
is a stamp of approval and you don't
feel comfortable that don't go man
um i'm raising my son to be there for
his friends i'm raising my son to be
there for people who are struggling and
i don't think
my presence is always a explicit
support as much as i want people to know
i love you i'm gonna stand here with you
i love you
i'm gonna give you my presence so man
thanks for the call
um that's a tough one dude good luck
with that one all right let's go to gwen
in chattanooga tennessee
gwen what is up hi
hi how are you how are you outstanding
good
what's up good well okay so
i'm 36 i'm married i have four boys
and hey hold on hold on
hold on will you do that again for me
yeah and i want you to do it where the
end of your sentence doesn't curtail
down but it curtails
up okay okay
so the way i heard that was i'm 36
i have four boys and i think i want to
set my hair on fire
and i want to hit my own feet with a
sledgehammer
let's do it the other way and then come
out and say i'm 36
i've got let's do it like that okay okay
ready go okay so i'm 30. okay i'm 36
i'm married i have four boys um i've
reached a point in my life where i just
feel like i'm
really struggling um just
with um i guess my expectations
versus my reality yeah i can hear it
even when you said you're gonna be like
all right i'll talk more positive
it went right back down so what's what's
why are you struggling between your
expectations and your reality
okay so um i'm sorry
no don't be sorry this is hard stuff
okay
yeah that's tough um
so my mother suffered with mental
illness and
um like schizophrenia manic depression
bipolar who knows really okay so hard
stuff though
yeah yeah so i spent you know most of my
childhood with her
and yeah i just i promised myself when i
was a little girl that when i was grown
i was going to do
all the things that i needed to do to
you know live a good life and
you know have happy family and do all
the things and i feel like i've done all
the things but
it just hasn't fixed it you know what i
mean like
i still feel broken and i don't want to
i don't want to feel this way anymore
yeah i'm so sorry i feel like it's
starting to overflow into like my
and i don't know why it just feels like
all of a sudden
at this point my life it feels like it's
bothering me more than it ever has
um you know i don't want to be a moody
person or irritable
or short with my husband or my kids or
you know any of the things but i'm here
and i don't know how to get out i don't
know how to get out of this place that
i'm
in yeah have you met with somebody
before
i have not okay it's not something i
really i have ever really talked about i
just
you know just i just haven't
um tell me about your dad
um you know he was a good man he got
custody of my sister and i when i was
11. um you know he did the best he could
he was an
alcoholic sort of like you know he drank
a lot but he
kept a good job and did the best he
could
is your mom still alive
as far as i know i have not seen her in
25 years so
i have not you know i have no um
i have no idea really um and i think
that's one of the things that
bothers me a little bit i don't have a
relationship with her i don't want a
relationship with her
sure um and i feel guilty for them
sure um so here's here's
um i'm gonna be as honest with you as i
can okay
okay um so first
when i heard your voice when you picked
up the phone
and i i when you said hi and you started
talking about yourself
my instant feeling when you
curtailed your words down
was that you've had a really gnarly it
was instant
you've got something in your soul that's
been there a long long time a really
gnarly past and
right when you told me that your mom's
got schizophrenia and or bipolar and or
who knows
and you come from a loving yet alcoholic
father
you had two people on planet earth who
were assigned
to let you know that you were loved and
that you were valued and that you were
worth
something and that you were worth
something
they showed you that through their
attention
through their boundary setting through
their showing up
and you didn't get that
you didn't get that and i want to tell
you that sucks it's not the way it's
supposed to be
your mom was sick your dad was sick and
he was doing the best he could
but she didn't get that
and so before we go anywhere else i want
you to tell you that
you're loved and i'm sorry that that
happened to you okay
thank you you've got some
deep trauma wounds and you're gonna have
to get with a professional who's gonna
walk you back
and you're going to have to it's not
going to be long doesn't have to be for
the rest of your life
but you're going to have to process some
of that stuff because here's the deal
you've spent the last 20 years healing
from that
and my guess is when you grow up no i
know this but my guess is
you've spent the last 25 35 years making
sure everyone around you is okay
making sure everybody around you has
everything that they need
and you've really been trying to chase
peace and
you've been trying to chase stability
through making sure everyone around you
is okay
in these external things
and that's not where you find peace you
find peace from the inside out
and usually we find peace when we're
tethered to something and you were shot
out of the cannon completely untethered
and it's not your fault
and so i want you to know that you're
loved you're a person of value
your husband loves you your kids love
you but you're gonna have to do some
work from the inside out
okay okay and i wish there was something
on this radio call that i could say you
need to go do these four things and it's
gonna be all right
but it's going to be hard i also want
you to know this
it's okay to put your mom down to stop
carrying her around with you
okay it's okay to put your dad down
and stop carrying him around with you
okay tell me about your husband
he's a good man yeah he's great he's
he's my rock he's
wonderful great dad do you trust him
yeah absolutely do you trust him with
everything
i mean absolutely i have no reason not
to um okay
does he tell you that he loves you never
really oh yeah
yeah does he tell you that you're
beautiful
yes does he tell you that you're a good
mom
yes all right i want you to believe him
okay because right now you're listening
to voices
it is because you're listening to voices
that have been talking to you since you
were four years old
and five years old and six years old and
those voices are
take care of dad watch out for mom
everybody be quiet you're not good
enough
and those voices have been in your head
and they've been in your head and
they've been in your head
and i want you to start listening to the
other voice in your head that tells you
you're beautiful
you're a great mom he picked you out of
all the people he could have picked
and that you're awesome
okay okay but i want you to make me a
commitment that before
tomorrow is over you're going to call
somebody in your local area you're going
to call counselor you're going to call a
marriage and family therapist
you're going to let them know i've got a
history of some trauma
some history of some mental health
issues with my mom some severe mental
health issues
some addiction with my dad and
i'm ready to do the work now so that i
can become whole from the inside out
okay okay and okay
i want you to call me back in a month or
two after you've had a couple of
sessions
okay and when you call
even if you gotta fake it i want you to
call and say
um my name's gwen
i've got four kids four crazy smelly
weird
hairy boys and i've got a husband that
loves me okay
okay is that fair yeah
you promise you're gonna call somebody
in the next 24 hours
yes i will do it you're brave gwen
you're brave you're brave
and i want you to know this too gwen
everyone listening to this
just sat back and exhaled a little bit
when you said you would and i want
everyone listening to this
everybody watching this to recognize
gwen's bravery and i want you to know
you're brave too and if you got to make
a call to go sit with somebody
and let them know hey this is what my
childhood was like i need to work
through some stuff so that i can be
present here for myself present here for
my kids present here for my current
husband for my wife go do it go do it go
make that call
gwen you are a rock star you're awesome
trust that guy you married and then
trust the professionals that you're
going to get involved with good for you
all right let's go to emilia in billings
montana
amelia what's up hi dr d thank you for
taking my call
thank you so much for calling what's up
so when i was 18
i just left home
okay and i just walked out how come
why'd you leave
um unhealthy and toxic
environment and controlling
um and so before i was just done
before you leave what does that mean was
it uh abusive
or were people just giving you mean
curfews or strict curfews what does that
mean
toxic and controlling um
like i would say verbally um
like you don't deserve this verbal put
down
um a lot of like immune comments
based on the mood of one of my parents
um so and that's been five years
um from now almost five years so
i'm wondering how i should reach out to
my family
and also if i should reach out to my mom
and
how to help her
so have you had any contact with him in
five years
um especially over the summer i started
contacting um some of my siblings and
talking about their experiences
have a little bit of contact with my dad
um but i haven't seen or talked to my
mom
so are you i don't really understand
what you're asking me are you asking
how do you call and reconnect with your
mom
how do you get back in touch with your
whole family what do you what do you
drill down for me what are you asking
um how do i know when it
stays for healthy and to
like restart that relationship
does your mom have mental illness is she
well
i think she does have some sort of
mental
illness i i don't know what and it's
probably
undiagnosed and untreated okay
um you know it's safe when
you have boundaries that you firmly
established and people don't cross them
and so that's how you know you're safe
when you say i only tolerate people in
my life who talk to me
respectfully and who don't put me down
and
they may tell me things i don't want to
hear that's just called accountability
that's called friends who actually love
you it's called parents and family
members who actually love you
but they don't put me down they don't
beat me up they don't talk to me
disrespectfully
they're honorable people to be around
and that's how you know
my heart rate doesn't get up when i
think of talking to them
i don't lose sleep knowing i have a
phone call with them tomorrow or that
i've got a
coffee date with them tomorrow i don't
always look forward to it but i don't
get
you know right my my body's alarm
systems don't go off
when you talk to your dad does it still
freak you out or have you reconnected
and it's wonderful to hear his voice
again
yeah it was um super awesome to talk to
him
and it was great so i i feel like i'm
missing something here why don't you
just go home and see your mom
why don't you call her and say i'm gonna
be home on friday and let's go to lunch
um
she's pretty mean okay then why don't
you just not call her i
well i guess i did that for the past
five years
um but i just
want to help her i guess
even though it's hard to have
contact with her what do you want to
help her with
she's all alone sort of she's
burned a lot of relationships even with
her um
like brothers and sisters um my aunt and
uncle
she's burned a lot of relationships and
i think she
really needs a lot of help so amelia
this is gonna suck
but i'm just gonna be honest with you
okay you can't fix your mom
you can't fix her you can love her
and you can be in a relationship with
her but if she
let her 18 year old daughter walk out
the door and hasn't tried to reach out
and connect with you
and if she burned up her marriage and
her brothers and sisters
there's not a lot you can do
yeah you can go in there with some firm
boundaries and know my mom's gonna
be angry and she's gonna be mean and
she's got her own story from when she
was a kid
and she just needed someone to sit with
her and love her
and that's going to be noble like holy
work for you to go do that
but i want you to be real careful about
building a fantasy you're not going to
get back those last five years
yeah and even growing up
it wasn't a good relationship i knew she
was sort of
ill and he was always quite angry
um is it okay to
never talk to her again i guess
yeah if that's what it takes to keep you
safe yeah it is
i'm i'm a big fan of never giving up on
somebody
and so if i was in your shoes i would
send a letter with the number where they
could reach me
i would probably always make sure that a
few times a year i sent something in
writing just let them know i loved them
and i hope they were doing well and
i'm also going to be about the business
of making sure that i'm safe
and i'm not in an abusive relationship
and that my kids are safe and my spouse
is safe and those kind of things
but yeah when somebody for whatever
reason
and it sounds my guess is your mom went
through some really hard crap when she
was a kid
and she got stuck in some loopty loops
and has never
been able to come out it's never chosen
to come out and never done the hard work
to break some of those old
old cycles and sometimes when you get in
those cycles
you treat people a way that you wish you
hadn't of instead of saying i'm sorry
and leaning into fixing that it just
compounds that it makes that shame and
depression cycles spin faster and faster
and you find yourself all alone
and if you're struggling with mental
illness sometimes that stuff accelerates
it
or as a result of it and so
yeah if you're not safe stay away
it's not it's not your job to go back
and repair something that somebody else
broke
yeah what's your dad say
um sorry
no you're okay
um he's good he still lives with my mom
um they don't talk much
i think does he think you should call
your mom
um
she agrees that it's
she's kind of a toxic person so
i i don't think he thinks it's wrong for
me to not call her you
can i lean into something real quick
amelia you keep saying
kinda and a little bit and it's just
sort of mean
you're using real minimizing language
does your mom hurt you
does she tell you that you're a loser
you're not a good daughter and
you're never grateful for any of the
stuff that she gave you
and you're a jerk and she wished you'd
never been born she stays stuff like
that to you
or does she say things like man you
whine a lot
you're a grouch like what does she say
you're using really
evasive minimizing language um
like in high school i um probably
very obviously needed to go through
counseling and the school provided that
and
she'd say things like oh you're screwed
up in the head
you don't deserve to have friends you
don't deserve to
go outside it's pretty mean stuff
hey amelia moms aren't supposed to say
that to their kids
yeah i know and that's not your fault
all right left
amelia that's not your fault
you're not hearing me that's not your
fault
kids are supposed to have friends and
they are supposed to go outside
and they're supposed to be hugged and
loved
i'm sorry you didn't get that
thank you
and so yeah if your mom's not well if
she's not healthy
and she's going to hurt you again
it's probably not smart or safe for you
to head back in there unless you've got
some real strong boundaries
and you've probably got some training
you've probably got a counselor that's
working with you
but you're not gonna you're not gonna
fix your mom that's her work to do
and you're probably maybe it always
works this way in the movies but not a
lot in real life
you're probably not going to get an
apology from her
yeah i
yeah and hey
emilia you deserve one but you're
probably not gonna get it
and so grieving that loss putting that
down that fantasy down that myth down
that
my mom's going to circle back around and
be the mom like my friends had
it's probably not going to happen
and i hate that for you
do your brothers and sisters still keep
up with her
um i have a one sister that
probably hasn't talked to her since
seven or eight years um
and a younger sister that'll call
and touch face yeah amelia
there's just a family pattern here it's
time to let it go
it's time to let her go
and if your dad's a good man and he's
standing by her
and trying to be the best husband he can
be for sickness and in health
then good for him and keep connected to
him
and keep connected to your sisters
but yeah you gotta put that one down
and you can still love her you can love
the idea of her
um but you're not going to get that one
back you're not going to fix that one
and i'm sorry to tell you that i know
it's heartbreaking
i cannot recommend enough that you get
somebody whether it's a minister or a
friend that you can be vulnerable with
or a group there in your community or a
counselor someone you could walk
alongside for a short time
just to help process and grieve this
properly
and then yeah set it down and that's so
hard you set down your freaking mom
she set you down man and she obviously
had some stuff in her heart that
just made her bitter against the world
and who knows what her story is and i
bet it's traumatic and hard too
but that's not for you to fix or solve
so i'm sorry that she hurt you i wish i
had better news for emilia but yeah you
gotta put that one down
thank you so much for trusting me with
that call for being vulnerable
that was a hard one all right let's take
one more call let's go to
uh let's go to mark let's go to mark in
illinois what's up brother mark
hey dr john uh good to talk to you today
you too good man that's
a yeah i've got a interesting one for
you
okay i am an er doctor and uh
have had to i've tried to lead some good
team debriefs after some
pretty awful cases we've had over the
last few months
and i was trying to figure out if there
are any good resources for ways to
improve
the ability to kind of work on the
leadership side of things for that and
to
kind of help oh guide the
debrief process for it because i i
really believe that's an important thing
for
all the staff members after some of
these rough cases we've had but
i just wanted to see if there's any good
tips you've had because i think
uh listening to the show in the past
you've had some definite experience in
this area
yeah i man i'm glad you weren't on my
last show
uh we batch uh we we batch record some
of these shows and
the last show that i did i kind of went
on a rant about um
firemen and police officers and
physicians
and all sorts of leaders who don't uh
honor the people that work for them
especially when they're working the
messy broken lives of other people
and so of course as fate would have it
you're on the next show man so i want to
tell you i love you
and i'm really proud of you being a guy
who not only goes in
and is with people and families in the
absolute
pit of despair and their hardest hardest
most traumatic moments literally
but i also want to thank you for being a
good leader and a good
man in a hard hard situation caring for
the people who are caring for other
people
that makes you a special man mark so i
appreciate you
all right appreciate that as well um so
my certification
i went through a training process it was
cism critical incident stress
management and there's one for group and
there is one for
individuals i will go back and i don't
remember exact school that it was from
but i will put it in the show notes
and you can check on it um the guy who
trained us it was a week-long training
not to mention the the regular crisis
response we were doing live
but uh it was really a remarkable
training
and i can give you a couple of the high
level
tips that i carry with me to this day
that make some of those after
after action debriefs help them be
healthy
and help them be something that supports
everybody and lets us all
go home and come back the next day
something i say often
is when you work in an er when you work
in those crisis response moments
even teachers right even teachers who go
into schools and out of schools every
day
it's like working sanitation it's like
working in the sewer and you've got to
put on your
suit but then you got to hose that thing
off when you get done
before you go home and take that stuff
home and before you get all over your
house get all of your kids and your wife
and your husband and those kind of folks
right
and so what what what those debriefs are
is just those check-in moments right
and i know you know this i'm telling the
folks who are listening these are these
check-in moments when you circle
everybody up after
a bad car wreck when three or four
people die in a traumatic car wreck or
um when children especially those are
always hard for me personally but
um they're just intentional circle ups
is everybody doing okay
anybody have anything to say um before i
launch into these
have you how have you led those in the
past give me a scenario
well i guess one of them was a
particular bad day
similar to the examples actually that
you just
mentioned there and uh it was one that
you could tell the
ems crews on steam had a really rough go
of it yeah so i've just mentioned to the
chargers hey
we need to get a at least a wet debrief
here to try to get as many people to
get this one off the mind as oh we can
so called back the ems crews that had
been out and about still and got as many
of the staff that hadn't already left
for their shift
later on in the evening just went to the
conference room and
i just started off with kind of talking
over the
medical things that were going on and
then
how how ugly of a case that was and how
it's not something that
anybody's supposed to have to see and
just trying to trying to pull
some input from the crowd as to things
that
they thought went well things that could
have done better and
and is trying to see how everybody's
doing with it and
get some individual kind of emotion
feedback as well on it
okay who was in that group with you
we had a bunch of the nurses
the text the other talk that was
involved with some of the other cases
was able to
pop in briefly with it and then several
of the
ems providers were able to come back to
the hospital and i'll be there as well
which
yeah some of those were students in
training so that was a
definite rough day for them yeah so
um so here's a couple of things that
um i remember that were they were real
clear on
and it has to do with processing not so
much
as you mentioned dealing with so you can
put it down or leave it but it's
think of it more as of as a way for it
to
come into you you've seen this and for
those of you who don't know and are
listening ems folks
trauma nurses er doctors they will
see things in a given day that most
people could never imagine
they can never they could never believe
that they just saw what they saw
and so i want you to think about it more
uh mark is
not a thing that you see and that you
just get rid of
it literally has to cycle through you
and what a good debrief does
is it provides community it provides a
group of people of with a shared
experience
one thing that's real important about
those groups is that they are uh
homogeneous
and that's a you know that word but it's
a nerd word for saying
it's of people of the same profession
the same status the same place
and so one of the errors i've made
before that i learned was
if you get and i'll just use your
example if you put a couple of doctors
and charge nurses and trauma nurses and
a few straggling ems folks all in the
same room
there's all sorts of power hierarchies
going on at the same time
and nurses a nurse may be apprehensive
to say something because she may have a
performance review with that
doctor that didn't go well three weeks
ago and this nurse doesn't want to look
weak because she might get promoted it
just makes things messy
and so one of the the first things i
would do is to split people up in groups
that are just nurses
just ems folks just the maintenance and
facilities folks who saw things
and even if it's just two or three or
four doctors um
just two or three or four frontline
staff do those debriefs they don't have
to be long but do them with just those
those small groups because nurses will
talk to nurses right doctors will talk
to doctors
um the second thing is something to
remember and this was this surprised me
but it was
most people don't need extra help most
of the time
and so we may you may see i may have
seen as a crisis respond to a really
gnarly suicide or a really
messy car wreck a really ugly
heartbreaking car wreck
um and i may it may impact me in a
certain way
but then i was able to get up tomorrow
um
journal about it talk to a couple of
friends talk to my supervisor about it
and then i'm
i'm whole and i'm ready to go back in
usually it's just one or two people that
aren't are really get stuck in there and
they're struggling so it's to keep an
eye out for the outliers and then
another thing that's important is a
weekly report tool
some sort of regular are these nurses
always checking in with their doctor are
they always checking in with their
floor supervisor in a regular way and
here's why that's
important if you only have check-ins
when things are going wrong
it tends to shift the entire bell curve
of the er
it tends it shifts the bell cover the
entire culture
so having regular check-ins even when
things went great that day
which in an er in an er right is never
great but
um if you have check-ins at the end of a
week or at the end of every other day or
just 10-minute get-togethers and
this is going to sound cheesy because
nobody's got time to do this especially
in er
but if there are daily or weekly or
monthly shout outs
led by the doctors you're talking about
culture change from the inside out
because you all
are you all own the power there y'all
are the go-to guys
we all the men and women who are are at
the top of the heap there
and if y'all come in and say i saw this
nurse doing something incredible
i saw susan was struggling and she went
home that day and i want to applaud her
for her bravery and for taking herself
out so she could be well and then come
back
now you're talking really strong
systemic culture change
but it keeps it from just getting
together when there's things that are
bad
um yeah and then the
um let's see here compassion and
flexibility with yourself and with your
team
i told the story once on this podcast it
hasn't come out yet but it will come out
soon
i responded to something i had a little
girl i responded to a christ situation
that involved a little girl
and i looked at my partner and i did the
no-no i left my partner
i said i can't do this i gotta go and
she janiece she was incredible and she
said i got you
but i had to be flexible with myself and
i couldn't beat myself up the next day
so i called my supervisor and said hey
i had to step out of this one and my
partner stepped up
and i apologize to her and she's like
man i got you and we have flip-flopped
that role before
but it's being flexible with yourself i
know you as er doc you can't do that
right sometimes an er nurse can say hey
i've got a five-year-old son
and that five-year-old little boy on
that gurney i can't be in the room right
now and somebody steps up
and everybody knows that's okay to do
here now i know
every hospital is in staff that way and
every social work office isn't staffed
that way but there's something about the
compassion and flexibility
and then i'll tell you the most
important thing on a debrief this is the
last thing i'll leave you with
is you as the doctor man if you model
compassion
and you model humanity and you model
as the leader as the head honcho you
model hey this really hurts and this
sucks and i'm
i i'm struggling with this one this
one's hard
um you will give permission for everyone
that works with you and around you
to feel human too and most of the what
trauma does is it disconnects us from
our humanity you know that
um but it allows us to re-enter humanity
whether it's through tears or whether
it's through joy or whether it's just
witnessing somebody else be vulnerable
and you as the honcho use the er doc
being vulnerable
oh my gosh man what a gift brother what
a gift
and so getting everybody in the same
groups letting everybody be open doing
it on the regs
and then you being somebody who is
vulnerable and
shows that models that man you're going
to talk about a a
completely renewed culture in an er
that man can you imagine everyone in the
er being whole dude
and everyone's um it sucks and it's hard
it's ugly messy work but
they came in ready to rock and roll
because they were resilient and restored
man that
what a gift you'd be to that crew and to
the families who
are in their worst moments right yep
man um can i again
mark i just want to tell you thank you
thank you for what you do
it's hard hard hard work well yeah i
certainly appreciate having the
opportunity to
try to be helpful on stuff do you have
uh you married you got little ones
uh married in a little bit at this point
okay sometime in the future
it's yeah it's in the future good deal
well um do me a favor i want you to
go home tonight and i want you to go to
your spouse and say
um tell him that you love him tell her
that you love her
and that you are grateful for her and um
connect with her in a meaningful way and
that's going to begin a journey of
resilience it's going to be powerful and
strong
whoa whoa all right so as we wrap up the
show
and today's song of the day the greatest
song ever written
not in the 60s not in the 70s not in the
1800s but in 1984
a young man that many hadn't heard
before
may have borrowed a song from huey lewis
but ray parker jr hit the scene
and he taught us where to go when we
don't know what to do
ray said if there's something strange in
your neighborhood
who are you going to call ghostbusters
if there's something weird and it don't
look good
who are you going to call ghostbusters
you know what ray said he ain't afraid
of no ghost nope
i ain't afraid of no ghost if there's
something strange in my neighborhood who
am i gonna call
ghostbusters and this is the dr john
deloney show